As a poker player,
you,
you can't have a consistent style and be
successful over time.
Uh,
your opponents come to know how you play
and they will devise a strategy to beat
you if there are any good.
So while you can have over overarching
tendencies,
um,
you,
you really can't stick with one way to
play and be successful.
And I think that's pretty much the same
for business.
It's either evolve or die.
Um,
and you,
your strategy at the poker table and in
tournaments has to evolve over time
depending on the circumstances in that
tournament.
And your strategy in business has to
evolve.
Your competitors are always trying to
get the best of you.
And if you don't,
uh,
take advantage of holes that they open
up or holes that they attempt to close,
then you can be pretty sure that your
business isn't going to last very long.
Same thing at the poker table.
What a strategy that may be working
perfectly in the early stages of the
tournament,
maybe suicide in the middle stages of
the tournament.
And a,
you always have to be both a aware of
your image at the table and,
uh,
and what's your opponent's think of you
and,
and then try to constantly rearrange
your strategy so that they are doing the
wrong thing against you at the right.
Yeah.